let's see what's going on for the
YouTube make sure to turn your desktop
audio don't you see it's alright I think
we're good
and we are love welcome to the iron law
podcast and the Lords of gaming dotnet
episode number 121 it's another glorious
Sunday we're back at the roundtable on
the Lord's Day and we've got Gamescom
predictions hallo infinite departure
multiple Bioware departures xbox game
studios multiplet and play NYC recap to
discuss so we go get right into it so
let's introduce the well we ain't got
for the king is down man please man
reach out to the king man he is not
doing well he has been falling he's guy
he's a little sick right now so please
reach out to him wishes to our brother
the premium experience he shall be back
in the realm surely but we're gonna try
to hold it down in his absence but we
still have the co-host with the core
most my brother from another mother the
difficult game conqueror Lord of reviews
and the half of the young folk mommy
so I found the guide in extension on
Mike pretty good so a little tired I
don't know how I'm gonna handle this
11:00 a.m. stuff we bout to do I might
have to be sick for like two months and
sure 808 brother what you could play of
it what sorry I said September 8 what
you've been playing them uh every plane
man to be honest with the oven playing
destiny yeah like Mario Odyssey and then
I dropped Mario to see like the same day
I started playing it I just can't get
into that game I really don't feel Mario
Odyssey like
a morning every time I start to play
like I don't know why I just I just
can't be not a fan were you not a fan of
64 and like sunshine
I like those games but there's just
something wrong about this game Oh super
shots say like super chats
let's take this opportunity to recognize
the king still trying to avoid given the
needs to solve are you saying that like
this is the day he had to give the knees
up and since he didn't want to he called
and sick dizzy I have to say I think
you're onto something Lord this little
game rule is for the single player
selfish experience and also the Sascha
Thomas mr. Flom profile Illuminati and
Laura patreon of the iron bake mommy
Lord sovereign are you doing sir I'm
good bad I'm chilling man
get some rest man yeah you know me I
never get any rest so yesterday I was
out all day but I felt rested I came
back home with chilling wife you know
Saturday's date day so you know this is
a sad thing I haven't finished a game I
don't know how damn
so I finally finished blood stain ritual
of the night how was I was a great game
man great game I to me still I mean I
still think Symphony of the Night is to
go like there's nothing but touching
that but that the most ain't is good is
very good stories very cool has a lot of
the same you know obviously the same
tropes that is symphony of the night you
know the earth but we we do that point
out that she couldn't play it on the SOI
yeah the kid nighty
but I agree with they have to give you
that one that it was yeah honestly I
heard that switch parties have one patch
but that hasn't done much of anything
shout the state she said keep the switch
talk to a minimum today I don't see that
I don't see in color no that's pretty
much it
oh yeah apologies to addict because I
saw that he messaged me while I was
passed out in front of the TV I happen
to be on xbox but I saw it later on
camera addict was trying to talk to me I
was passed out in front of blood state
premium king of statues he is out of
commission right now you see the cops
going crazy right now they are all sad
cuz Kings now yeah of course we have the
law of the cooperative experience and
gaming into himself this shinobi law
Cognito
spreading that realness in the realm of
the ILP not telling you what you want to
hear but what you need to hear so I'm
for me man it's just been uh got that do
a big battery switch man oh yeah that
games I've got the good deal yeah I
gotta check it out game stops really out
here I think for your own switch about
seventy bucks you can be in the round
doing it up you know I'm saying so I
definitely picked that up and I'm great
they have like extra training or
whatever so it's been good probably up
to about um September's when they doing
this deal solve so you got a little time
but you could tell like a new one come
in a red box and it has a different arm
serial on it so I've been doing that and
then um something I picked up always it
mark of the ninja remastered oh yes that
the greatest stealth games ever made so
I don't never know about this games like
I never know like it's pure stealth with
them actually but it an animation is lit
yo it's crazy man Sulu are so Chris
Marquis Park Polly oh that's what's up
but um yeah man that's been that for me
and I'm trying to think what else aw I'm
a little fell seal and of course some
destiny
to prep going on you know I'm saying cuz
cross st. drops this week so that's been
what's been going off for me you know
I'm saying but um we got our two a two
week ago that does drop it a Tuesday
doesn't it oh man I had a date Tuesday I
think I might the cancel that clearly a
GU say why do you know I'm I get sick I
thought but you're coming on oh good we
got a two week ago poll that we gotta
get into the people have spoken to the
question with the recent signing of
ninja away from twitch to the mix of
platform what do you think about the
impact of this move for Microsoft the
winner of the three-way ILP poll when
their commanding seventy seven percent
of the vote was yes ninja was a huge
signing for the future of Microsoft
services and engagement group coming in
at second place and only 13% of the vote
was the no mixer stays third place
behind YouTube and twitch and wait games
at last place at a close ten percent was
that I don't care until ninja drops off
the bag or my Mexico stream so what do
the Lord's think of this how did they
let you go first it's not of my
generation stream you know you know
stream he's not really my generation
either right like you you can adapt like
you know Internet your generation are
you started can leave me you know me
barely look at you in text so you
thought you generation I mean it is what
it is like it's ninja they had every
reason to get that due to no reason not
to get that people like people like all
he was dethroned like do you see it
realize how dumb that sounds when people
say that oh he's not as busy used to be
I mean I'm not the biggest like in
basketball or anything but if what's
who's the best player right now in
basketball all you do is say LeBron -
okay who's the second-best player I was
seeing Kevin Durant look would you get
just because the bran got dethroned by
Kevin Durant would you not get LeBron I
just didn't understand that like oh yeah
when King was saying that did do like
does he regularly beat him in views
whoever this other dude I forgot his
name was it does he regularly beat him
whether he beat him once
I think he's consistently beating him
now but why I mean obviously everyone on
Twitch is beating you now real quick
really I thought it was I knew it was
gonna be there were gonna be some hotly
contested fights I knew people come in
there to fight so I'm like you know what
this is gonna be good
this is gonna be good because you know
sometimes you get here to miss with some
of these easy these you know ko main
events and things of that nature but I
have to say man the top three fights
they brought it they really really
brought it definitely I mean for me you
know obviously the standouts was the
main event the co-main event right you
know the Diaz and Pettis joy that was
that was a bomb burn I mean tremendous
Jiu Jitsu scrambles on the ground oh
that was that way if you love if you
love you get to that my boy medicine to
chadsey Farzin it but it's like if you
love the talent you understand the
talent the level of jiu-jitsu that was
being displayed because exactly you know
I'm saying at the other day Diaz Gracie
you just he's he's this level he showed
how much better he was but I have to
give Pettis credit for not quitting
still scram and reverse in a couple of
situations you know I'm saying but at
the end of the day Diaz just a little
too big the pressure was too much you
know I'm saying boy what did you think
what do you think so no I agree
completely I think like when you talk
about all the answers that dude was wait
three years three years he's just that
good this is old hat for him like if
there's ever an argument for the lack of
somebody having like ring rust it's it's
the
he doesn't like it he's not fazed by
this at all he can be away for as long
and he came back and he looked good you
could tell his cardio wasn't quite where
normally is right he was getting a
little tired which was surprising to me
but that's that's where Pettis could had
that opening um but I just think I did
Diaz again yeah he is kind of physically
was a little big for Pettis in terms of
being able to sort of throw him around
and whatnot and ultimately he was able
just to sort of match them move from
move on the ground
yeah and that's what put him over the
top but I thought it was a great fight
how well contested fight um Pettis
sometimes I don't know I think sometimes
Pettis is his own worst enemy because I
feel like he still wants to do flashy
things I yeah he's not really there
anymore like the speed isn't quite there
anymore it's a guy I would rather him be
more boring and I think with him I don't
necessarily think the move up was a
great move because even when he beat
wonderboy I was like yeah it was not
that you lucky he's skilled enough to do
craziness that he could beat anybody
right right but at the end of day if you
stick to the game plan and you press him
you take the kids away he's gonna slow
down like dos ángeles set the blueprint
to beat him and you know he never really
recovered and then the other thing is
just like I don't know man you know
saying like I think you need to go down
to B I don't think this goes back to
where like he's older it may be more
difficult for him to be at that weight
class so it's easier for him to not kill
himself in training camp and be at this
weight class and hope that his power
translates and it that's the thing that
he does it so at this point like I said
you can't get away with trunk with the
flash now because you don't have the
strength you don't have the speed you
have to be boring if you want to win or
else they're gonna cut you they're gonna
cut you I mean again he can still he
obviously you could put on an exciting
fight but I just think he does he
doesn't have that little extra you need
to get him over the top especially if he
continues
right the way he's always fought ya know
I think you know this off and then um
you know we'll see what happens with
goes on with Nick come moving forward
they talk about amaz modality I'll be
crazy and I will be doubt himself right
now
cubed Jesus out see yo well bro quick
did you see the drama between Pettis in
at Brent Askren no all right no quick
Ricardo this we go along but yo fast
patty I think y'all Marrero show Pettis
the knock out of a screen it was like
yeah he got what he deserved
apparently Pettis in a screen are
teammates so they somebody recorded it
and send it back to me asking like yo
you need new friends Pettis out here
laughing at you getting stretched it so
yeah it was it was I don't know yeah
what do you think I think more and more
UFC has gotten very WWE a lot of this
stuff could be placed you know just to
mix fights exciting but uh I we'll see
we'll see but um real quick on the main
event though like start out to Steve a
man in that first round he looked
outclassed a hundred percent I was like
all guy he doesn't belong in the ring
with this like Daniel just picked him up
and tossed him like a rag doll he was
punching him in the face he wasn't
respecting his power and then you know
steep a just wrote it out honestly like
when somebody has knocked out and
steeper he's always had a little bit of
a Fame of not having the greatest chin
so when he got put out last time I said
I don't know he's now if Cormier is not
afraid of his power he steps in it it's
gonna happen again it's just gonna
happen again and not it didn't happen he
took some good punches from Daniel he
rolled that out he really did look out
class in that first round a little bit
better in the second round better yet in
the third round and then he just he
switched up his game plan in the fourth
and went to the body just put the wind
right out of Daniel and then it just
barrage those body shots bro the day he
was digging them like yeah every one of
them joining us out the raceworld in the
chat
petty last night we watching the plane
I'm talking about there was big cactus
macaques Emma Emma may do and we talk
all back and forth and he's like yeah
bones and I'm like why don't both Jones
way and always have to talk about roles
during a DC but like boy fight night I
find it funny that anytime DC fights
they still bad dude no issue like it's
been shown he's not and especially not
at like heavy that's to say that's too
he can be cool me it could be anybody
else at light-heavy
what and heavy I honestly feel like
could beat anybody I had he did he his
game plan was dumb yesterday he felt he
was feeling himself too much that he
could take steep face punches and you
heard your ogen-sama that steep a could
knock you out I he standing with you and
you're not hurting him considerably then
you always have to be worried if you've
got knocking you out
did you see the that petition going
around trying to get Joe Rogan's to do
the Candida Steve a daily boy is that if
listen let's not act like Steve a wasn't
defending what his face for three rounds
yo he was great I was tweet like what is
the game plan like you're just gonna
keep getting hit punched in the face by
the show to do no reads no reason like
why is this little guy getting up in
your section for no reason you know I'm
saying so I like I didn't understand
that so it's like okay I get it you know
saying but he's the bigger guy and the
credit to him that adjustment he made me
it was around for yeah
ma'am what are the best Ajay could I saw
it take its toll and I saw plexus
roughly I'm losing you here that you
feel the skin roughly so I seen it but I
was like okay cool but um I didn't
expect that and I gotta give it to Steve
babe really
hanging tough you know and I guess I
mean if that was his game plan to just
take only output weight from the tire
out and then um he broke no thumb yeah
it was a weird way to rope-a-dope
somebody cuz he's ready he's getting
pounded and I didn't understand that at
all but again if he felt he could take
his punches and see where that took him
hey more power to him I work for him
this time it's very difficult to change
up strategy in the middle of a fight
like that if I like you I don't care how
long you've been a professional in the
middle of a fight you're exhausted
you're searching for air you're probably
not thinking straight you know to be
able to switch up your game plan and
have it work that way is a testament so
again shout out to steep they got the
belt again let's see if you can hold on
to it because you know the heavyweight
division is is crazy so I don't know man
I mean if at this point he's run through
everyone oh and again he's getting a
little older it may be more difficult
for him to to sort of drop weight if he
has to do that during training camp
let's see how his power translates going
up hey hey the thing is he could do it
once and he you know he's getting a
title fight he's not going away not
getting one of the old G's of ILP
history it has been a long time since
I've seen that avatar in this chat
salute to mummy Lord ache of it veto
version 2 let's go at all this I heard
you guys were lacking some premium
experience today here we go what
happened to version 1 I've been good the
usual move doing stuff it's a young
man's game
I appreciate you holding us down again
for those who just joined the king is
sick he's not fraud and playing switch I
see you old school plays switch without
a king he looks good reach out to King
he's not doing well
you definitely he's under the rope right
now so getting better healing up told a
man to rest feel better but ah we got a
man in the building man what you've been
playing Elise are you gonna get a chance
to play 76 man really it's been it's
been a blast to play like they've been
they've been working hard on updating
that game but for everybody I Dave I
I've been really impressed with it you
know uh I was one of the few that loved
all the updates today we're talking
about you don't say I really do suck you
know what I'm waiting for I think I just
need them to get in that game Pass
anchor it's not happening anytime soon
like everybody asked me that I'm every
time all I can think about is if they do
it it's gonna be maybe summer next year
like this they're going too hard on
these updates for it to be free I think
would be the perfect boost to that
population and just give him I am not
sure about that because I I see a ton of
new people getting on every day and
they're playing it there playing late -
I was up till about two three o'clock
last night playing and I could I kept
seeing new people like jumping into all
level 1 level 1 level 1 like wow so I
shout out to the $2 super chat from
dizzy I can't can keep this the King
King can keep his knees polisseni 6 is
it me why he's Kings knees just to stop
the fallout talk Wow are we doing dizzy
shadow self
Phillie ego sub ashen Luca what's going
on Christopher hey Ric all y'all CEO so
let's get it to these times man we got a
lot to discuss so um first off is uh
Lord a dick man we've got some special
going on money a big game
so we've Gamescom so it's pretty much
like it's I think it's technically the
biggest event in them in the world right
in gaming yeah it's the biggest fan
event yes
we have that going on so we have an
inside Xbox I don't know if that's
tomorrow or the next day but you know
there are certain rumors going around
that they're gonna announce the studio
acquisition there you know we could
definitely talk about that what I really
want to go into really is uh you know
what exactly do you think that Xbox are
really anyone that's going to gangsol
can announce there's there's rumors that
Sony might be announcing something there
I have no clue on that they don't really
they've been quite quiet this whole year
but that's besides the point so what do
you guys think
Xbox mainly because they are one of the
biggest people that's gonna be there's
going to be showing four games come
let's see
I would assume more gears talk that are
they be kind of building up to that game
pad I like I said I don't think that's
still next year like it I think I know
it's because I think it eventually will
just gonna be a while because the
problem is gonna be with them as they
just kind of they're going too hard with
these updates too frequently and that's
too much money being spent on that and
if it doesn't work then they got thrown
a game pass but if it does work
oh wait they'll hold out anyway back
back again so Gears of War I think
that'll be the big thing we'll probably
see a good campaign mission like all the
way through everybody hyped for it
theoretically if they do do a campaign
mission and it's like something they
said they're gonna debut a campaign they
didn't really say what they're gonna do
with the campaign yeah well let's say
it's like something small
doesn't really answer anything do you
think they're gonna get obliterated over
that not I if it's sizable like you know
at least five minutes of it at least
five minutes of it that's fine because I
agree with it at that point it's only a
couple of weeks off I really don't want
to see much at this point if it's bad is
bad there's nothing you can do about it
there's no going back well I think the
reason that they might be doing this is
because they don't you know obviously we
can't give their definition of what's
bad what's good they don't think it's
bad and they in they're tired of the
narrative being thrown around that just
cuz they're not showing something it's
bad yeah yeah I mean yeah definitely I
would say I think five minutes of it is
fine I think that's I think we do get
that cuz they did say they were showing
did they give a timeline I don't know if
they said it was gonna be a Gamescom but
they specifically said they had a
timeline for when they were showing
campaign before launch it was like I
remember Rod Fergusson saying something
specific about they had that broken down
how they gonna they plan to do that so
we will see it before long I don't know
it's game mindset for this one is
similar for e3 I have no expectations
for it why just just stay stay
completely in the dark see what happens
if it happens great if it doesn't it
doesn't and you're not to be
disappointed I mean cuz right now like I
I just with Xbox is kind of a known
cloud I can't really take you defending
fallout 76 I can't really how do you
defend that guy but Microsoft completely
gets across the board for games come I
just don't because every year it's like
a flip-flop like you don't know that
you're gonna get that year it's gonna be
explosions or it doesn't feel bigger
this year than it did like like I feels
like they are putting more stock into
everybody like it's told yeah you also
mentioned something in reference to
[Music]
game studio announcement is that out the
club real yeah you know you're on he
said that you know he thinks that
they're gonna announce it out he has
been consistent in the past so you know
I don't really know Rosa dude I don't
know if if it's going to happen I would
say there's a good chance it happens and
if it doesn't happen it's gonna be at XO
because you know a lot of these insiders
go up information that's outdated but
it's not it doesn't necessarily make it
not true
it just means that you know they're at
the end they had a last minute change
and it made the information he got that
he got three months ago has been changed
by then and now it's not being showed
again scars could be shot at XO so I
think it's a good chance that that's
gonna happen now I have no clue will
games studio would be like uh after e3
anything is up for grabs at this point
these predictions man Gamescom yeah so
let's let's run everything down in order
of when stuffs gonna happen so I think
the first thing is a Nintendo indie
showcase so obviously they said it we're
gonna be here like 20 minutes of indie
stuff obviously stuff this you know but
on seeing that hasn't been made its way
to the eShop yet it's gonna be announced
there was also rumors about two games
that were gonna be specifically dropped
and they used the word hot was
specifically you so though it's rumored
that apparently superhot was updated on
the eShop but has not yet been released
there so that could be a leak so one of
them could be super hot and the other
one they're thinking might be hotline
Miami which has not made its way to all
this which yet um so that's that in
terms of other specific yeah I'm hearing
ory talk so obviously they you know cup
heads on there um and that's gonna kind
of bleed into my topic later on but yeah
um I definitely see Ori as being the
next one announced from Microsoft it's
gonna be on there so it makes sense the
game's pronounced for a long time it's a
good way to get people
who aren't in the Xbox ecosystem
interested in what is a great
platforming game and maybe you know have
have Ori to make its way there as well
so I think that's really interesting on
for Xbox I think yeah I you know I think
we're gonna see some gear stuff
obviously we're gonna hit here some like
break point stuff um I know that uh what
Blair Witch is coming soon so that's
something that they're gonna be talking
about um cuz I think they have to focus
on that game that game is essentially an
Xbox exclusive Xbox PCs and you weren't
even know you would know you wouldn't
even know and I know people just excited
about it because of the way the game
looks um another thing that I saw on
Matt's talk about just interesting just
quickly in the massive we're gonna have
shadow keeper destiny you know that's
probably nothing but it's nice to that's
a thing that you know the Bungie of
Microsoft so that we have stadia Kinect
since they detailed some of the pricing
models and stuff I'm sure they'll go
into more detail about that something
more concrete um but I they gotta show
the games now they gotta they got us put
up now right they didn't talking about
this they have to show these games in an
open environment actually working so
people can touch it and be like yeah
this works um
so I'm thinking that it's gonna be
beyond the Kinect they're gonna do I'm
sure there's gonna be a lot of stations
there so people can actually play and
get a real sense of how this work I said
we you know I played it you know I did
that trial thing earlier on um and but
but again that according to them that
wasn't even ideal conditions so what
we're supposed to get as the end product
is even better than that so and I was
impressed by by by what I played before
so I'm kind of anxious to see how that
works and how other people who finally
get their hands on it feel about it um
and then I at the end of the night we're
gonna
oh the official opening night in a sense
that's Keeley that's gonna be a lot of
Kojima there in the building so oh yeah
man I think I think we may be a little
underwhelmed by you know you that
statement they made like all these you
know however many games are gonna be
announced for the first time it might be
underwhelmed by what they actually are I
think they are putting more stock in the
show this year than they did last year
so I'm excited about it
just to hear though keep expectations no
it's not anything personal is that
that's not like I don't trust you but
it's just like you know I I don't know
if you're bringing it this year or next
year so with you bro like I am so with
you or that like keep it low what I'm
saying is like look I'm high for what
they're doing you know I'm saying as far
as like you know the kids calm open at
night firstly keep it low cuz I store
the neck so yeah it wasn't having a neck
so you know I would say you know there's
a decent little bit more chance it's
gonna be a really good show but since
there's a neck so don't expect any big
bomb drops it's like nothing for me
personally I'm more excited about the
opening night live yeah that to me when
is that at the end of the night so let
me say it's two o'clock Eastern Time
yeah so it's like that to me is what I
want to see you know I'm saying it's
gonna be a lot going there now again
what the gears gameplay even though I
disagree with the way it was show dive
we talked about that ad nauseam at e3 at
least you know it clearly this was the
marketing plan right so like they clear
it was using Gamescom as a jump-off
point to say okay boom this is where
we're gonna do this thing so you know
let's see what it got you know I'm
saying I want to see how they they show
out you know see if it looks good or not
you know
get the fear-mongering out the way if
not on cold real joint it would be
interested if Microsoft dropped a new
studio acquisition if they made an
announcement I think that would be cool
you know I'm saying and so for me like
all Xbox got to do show gears make it
look good you know one game studio
announcement would be nice I'm not
expecting if they did both of those I'm
fine with Xbox on their showing for
Gamescom but um as far as on Nintendo
they got a little Tendo direct world
thing the indie direct show exclusive I
want to see that obviously bungees got
shadow keep that's gonna be crazy they
definitely looking to show something you
know I'm saying so we gotta see what's
going on with that now I will tell you
how this we know Sony gonna show that
Kojima we've know that destron it's
coming stealing the show I'm just gonna
keep you know a thousand on that pull it
off I'm not gonna lie like normally like
I really can't forgive scum as much not
you know not that I should say I don't
care I don't really get hype for games
going right but yeah the first one
overall whatever not now what inside
Xbox is doing but overall I'm excited to
see what every one of the big three are
gonna do it seems like they all have a
little something to show and it could be
a couple special so any speculation on
what that that uh Microsoft studio might
be I know we've done this a million
times but well I mean is there's the one
that's bad ones floating around a studio
mvhr yeah never everyone's been talking
about that what's the longest time I
mean it's kind of like Old Faithful when
it comes to the prediction even if it
doesn't happen six years from now we
talked about buying six studio MBH are
we were talk about this forever other
than that if I had to guess
was it come back me in a minute uh is it
on that I want to talk about I wouldn't
bring it back to attic real quick about
even though we kind of low-key setting
shots inside Xbox shadow West wasteland
Blair Witch it says game Pass will be
expecting some no announcements there um
ghost recall breakpoint on this stage
merge two Metro the two and it's a you
know the what about inside expert could
we get our expectations of just a little
with that no no I
I'd rather come home and watch season
six of the 100 that's on that foot I
will catch the highlights on on IGN okay
I mean I don't because I'm a content
creator I'll probably watch it anyway
you know prod I might even stream it I
don't know I it's a - right it's the
a.m.
Oh remember that's ridicu I don't care
what time it is they should go okay your
reaction I'll be at work so you guys can
handle that most likely show there
because they said they're gonna save
that for on live but they probably gonna
show like a horde well maybe some other
day they've already announced that they
don't show horde at least at the very
least I think what they do is they'll
end it with like a Bri trailer like a
sneak peek of what they're gonna show it
and his exclusive thing kind of like ei
did with the
anthem gameplay right it's gonna be like
some sneak peak that's gonna get people
hype to go watch the rest of it I mean
it is what it is right Pramod whoopee
cuz I can't get to sleep till like 5:00
in the morning so I'm gonna be on like 5
hours of sleep so I probably will be
asleep what do you got inside Xbox after
we read that list does that excite you a
little bit more give you a little bit
more I mean again the same situation is
this gonna be the one that's the
doorstop or is this gonna be a little
we're just gonna sit back and wait again
I just I don't I don't I don't know like
even if I get the list of what's going
on there I don't know what we're getting
out of it yeah this is really mean much
beyond that the biggest thing I do want
to point out there is do you think it's
safe to say that Xbox got marketing for
destiny going on forward like it's on
their stage like I I don't I'm not sure
about that name namely just because I
think at this point they're trying to
say like hey we're not doing this thing
with Activision anymore we learned not
to deal with Devils in the first place
but they've got an argument where they
could be like budget Bungie is big
enough where they could promote on their
own they don't need to be asked almost
saying yeah that that's the thing that I
think this is more of like a gesture of
goodwill than anything else like we we
didn't forget about you know I've been
following a shouty bonds we've been
doing the whole last word thing recently
we've been following it and they have
been very clear and their mission
statements to say we are independent we
want to get on as much platforms as
possible but then to turn around and see
them on Microsoft stage I'm not gonna
lie it does my eyebrow raised slightly I
mean maybe it's probably nothing but
just good faith and they're gonna show
so my son's gonna be there maybe they
just say you know accommodate him you
may be very don't think
is that I think there's some kind of
deal going on with the marketing rights
because like I said like for a while now
like they've always showed something
small on Sony but you know like a
trailer or something but like it looks
like they're gonna show something
relevant at this like why would they why
would they show all these streams and
then and then like tune in for games
cause then you look at the games called
in our Microsoft stage it's weird
because the thing about it is it's like
the you know state they're so big as
it's part of the launch of stadia right
you're getting the game for free on
stadia it's one of the first games that
that will if it works well it's gonna
show what that platform can do
especially in a multiplayer setting so
it has to has to be a good launch on
stadia so I wouldn't it's it's a little
weird that it's not being touted more as
a stadia thing at this point but to
shout the bit bad bit games in a chat he
actually been a good point he's saying
that is no way because destiny is also
being pushed by Bungie with stadia
launch so he he's saying like just just
gotta be good because I will say they
were Pro mowing destiny too hard in
conjunction with and we know they're
gonna have the same the same thing they
did last time when they talked about the
pricing model and all that stuff that's
what they're gonna have let's fill
dominus just a bag of them I don't know
we gotta see this is very interesting
the whole Bungie thing anything else on
your TEDx will we move on she's got a
lot to get into sir this is King's topic
we gonna bring it up on halo infinite
got some news going on man looks like
the creative director believe his name
is uh Tim Longo and um yeah man he is
leaving leaving 343 and announcement was
made so it looks like Microsoft has
confirmed the departure they sent over a
statement they said roles and
responsibilities will change
to evolve and meet the needs of the game
and I believe they're now exact you to
producer Mary Olsen she will take over
campaign team and then all I believe the
guy Chris Lee he's still will remain
studio head of halo in finis so and it
has been a little bit of a tizzy but
what this news is you know one year
right before launch you know I'm just
want to bring this to the roundtable is
kings topic as far as what do the lords
think about this is this being overblown
is this a big deal you know where do we
stand that you know one of the leads you
know is the party of from Halo Infinite
before the launch so the red flag that
comes up for me right is the fact that
before he left he was placed in another
position that what was essentially a
demotion I mean if you are the creative
director and you change roles unless you
become head of studio or something like
generally is gonna be a demotion if not
just maybe a lateral move and so that's
the red flag to me right like the he's
he was sort of removed from that
position and ultimately decided to walk
away that's the way it looks
anyway red flag I mean and you know a
year out from from launch who knows how
much of this game is done maybe 60% of
the game is done um how much of that is
the campaign so it's just one of those
things where that that that kind of
makes my eyes go up a little bit because
of the way it happened if he had just
decided hey man after however many years
at 343 I've decided to move on I leave
the team in great hands whatever the
game is looking great that's not
necessarily what happened like there was
a there was a shake-up before that that
sort of seems like it it pushed him to
decide to walk away completely
that's what worries yeah Bungie got
burned by Sony on III think about it
that's back to the whole Bungie thing
you know saying bomb yeah as Kiwis I
think you may be onto something
mr.brother but uh yeah I mean back to
what we were saying as far as this turn
I mean is is this something we need to
look more into is it is it more than
what it was this guy's the motor moved
around they didn't like the direction
what did he get demoted to do we have an
answer for that see I don't know what
position he got moved into it just says
that he got moved into another position
and then I'll sleep right but is anyone
ever considered the possibility maybe
something's happened with his family or
something like that and maybe he's
doesn't have as much time as he used to
did he create a director they moved him
down so it's less intensive like if we
wouldn't move them out like if it was
that he would just he would have just
stayed where he was I mean what do you
move down but it feels like it feels
like he got demoted because of him and
then after he realized and didn't it's
like he got demoted and then after a
certain amount of time after being
demoted he's like you know what it's
just not for me like I got demoted like
the interview vetting service creative
director phthalo file had moved to a
different role a few weeks ago and then
according to two people familiar with
the goings-on at 3:43 this week he left
the company entirely so it is there's
definitely a sequence of events here
it's just interesting I mean I only
thing I could think of is like it unless
I'm playing devil's advocate for a
moment that's my purpose right now is
it's the idol there is a possibility
could be a situation where he just
didn't have the time as much as he used
to and so he took a lesser role that
would have been less intensive and so
but then it just wasn't working out and
so as I gotta go I think it's just
simple is he wasn't working out as a
creative director you know what what's
funny what's hilarious is you know all
these people on Twitter that are saying
stuff like hey low fives bad halo floors
bad they get rid of the creative
director halo 6 is gonna be bad he made
though the games burn theoretically you
should
- out out get assaults I saw a dr. JD
game with the $5 super chat he got
demoted then fired he was responsible
for the bad campaign of Halo 5 so don't
be worried been glad because will now
get a good campaign I'm just like at the
end of the day like you can't want
change and say stuff like this games bad
this games bad and then Midway I
wouldn't say it's Midway but they get
rid of the creator director which you
know what he's the foundation that he
put together for that games already
pretty much since son let's move earlier
game comes out next year
so you know you can't complain about
that and then when they go to get rid of
that key piece that it resulted in the
games that you hated then you're like yo
this is look it's low-key halo 6 gonna
be bad people even like it makes no
sense to me I feel like we got it met
like before a launch when a prominent
personally it you do feel away you do
feel it like what's really going on
right your point though and entrust
their what JD games and I hear what you
say cuz III feel where y'all go with it
look all I'm gonna say is this I'm with
JD on this point you own this part y'all
know how I feel about halo 5 campaign I
feel that was the biggest marketing
misdirection of what was the stories
they said it was probably in gaming
history I definitely agree with that
I was excited for this whole big
takeover I was like yeah remember me you
was awesome team lock we were starting
trouble it was fun they might kill
Master Chief is going down so just for
the fun and it get people hype and then
we get the game and it was nothing like
that it was just very my new interaction
between I think you know so if he again
I'm not throwing him under the bus
completely but if he under his watch has
something to do with that campaign and
he is no longer part and now they got
marry of Mary's bars or narrative is
better Mary did like we got a father I
was super Chad from super shots from JD
game room I saw what he was what he was
doing what did his annual game check and
Phil said oh no not again
you demoted I get this mess fixed you
have 14 months don't really have 14
months they would have like nine because
the last couple months
like if the games not done in the last
couple months like they have to they
have to extend the game or the game he
said you guys don't know the story
that's why you missed the market coming
for us I mean it is what it is they had
an entire chapter just talking to people
on a bridge below came I will go with
you but you know I think this is
literally just one of those things to
create a director wouldn't put at
putting out what he was told and he his
responsibilities were he was demoted to
someone that can handle that or
quote-unquote handle that and that dude
wasn't filling that and he left the
company I think that's literally what
happening here this man shot the
fastback he said he's always be crave
differences directions and work plates
not mean doom and gloom I get both sides
in like the fear monger side is gonna be
like it could have been it could have
been done for some competition reasons
like Mike he could have been trying to
be poached by someone else and Microsoft
sensed it and they demoted him and then
he left and before you know he's on a
surface somewhere in another company
like you know stuff like this happens
all the time the hardcore side I get is
gonna say look at yo developers leave
every day be like like I get it you know
say it's just you know again not to
stress the halo 5 campaign as far as the
misrepresentation of what they said this
story was gonna be to what we actually
got you don't saying I definitely felt
the way about that
now at the end of the day chrisley still
running things so that he's still at the
top of the totem pole you know I mean so
at that and that's that's nothing really
has changed but it is interesting to see
how much of an impact Longo would have
had and I get the vabis creative
differences I don't know what do you
guys think what I see is funny about it
too is these people attacking this this
this scenario I'm like where are these
people when the initiative keeps
poaching hi people with a Naughty Dog
like there's no doom and gloom there
like is I mean they took like two or
three high-level people in there a nurse
in there and their team but I think that
something is understood within the games
industry especially like but it's under
Sony but not microscope see this is the
reason why the initiative went to Santa
Monica right because all of the top
talent is there amongst a big first
party studio so yeah they post each
other all the time
it could just feed people you know
highly skilled people getting bored to
what they're doing jump into something
else right it's the him taking the job
right that's interesting yeah so I don't
know man I ox point like I just don't
think when it comes up sorry go back to
what you said cars specifically your
point what was the question
right right my thing is like we don't
know what's going on so let's be clear
none of us are in three four three we do
not know what's going on how much more
are we this is a Barney Ross like is
this I'm just trying to say is we don't
know you know some people have a title
but then there's some people that
actually do the work so I don't know the
level of impact and influence he had in
the creation of it that's that's where
I'm real concern like is he directly
respond because if he was directly
responsible for five then yeah my thing
is bushes because I didn't like fire it
but if he just had like mine overseeing
thing and then you know somebody else
was really hands-on in the trenches with
it then it's different you know I'm
saying so it's very real money he was
the creative director for five right so
creative vision the overarching vision
of five was on him I guess you assumed
that it's on him right so if that is the
case right and they didn't and he was in
that same position now and it did not
like what was going then I can
definitely see a mate at at the same
time there was like if that is the case
you're a year out from launch and if
they say that is the case right what how
do you rejigger an entire story entire
backbone of where I know is going next
in a year now I know that's spooky
is it disco if this goes good this is
this is how I'm gonna do it okay
this goes good on your say it's because
of this decision this decision got this
was and it just goes bad and we'll say
the same thing it was this decision it
was Microsoft that's what I'm gonna be
doing in a year for now I know about you
guys a day I don't think you make if
this guy's influences that big if you
make this change this late in the
development of it's not going to change
anything
well the this late in the game dude like
what we're looking at it right now
how how late in the game always you
don't say like I would say we're
probably we probably have nine months of
development timeline and this is the
guess what what happened like the Queen
gets delayed they shut out all shot the
fastback Lord addict taking the common
sense man to why Lord King is way throw
these overly concerned off shared
developers in the voices damn fast back
so get the second look at Ziggler he
gave a shout out to dollar super chat
it's all seems simple he made a bad
campaign in Halo 5 they were giving him
another side when they saw what he was
doing they demoted him he couldn't take
the same and at the end of the day like
is it concerning yeah but at the we need
to see first off I would be more
concerned that we didn't see nothing
when the dude was there we didn't see
nothing to e3 we saw we saw a do come up
lights come on he comes out and in a
campaign like I'm more concerned as the
studio as a whole
I am about one person leader and this is
the worry though right if this move
happens a year out from launch right and
it is because there's an issue with the
campaign with the overall creative
vision of Halo infinite what can you do
to that in a year's time that is not
gonna totally wreck the game I guess my
question to fast PAC game addict that
when is their time to be concerned when
when do you actually get alarmed when
you hear do you need for the game comes
out and it gets a 69 say like what is
the criteria for you guys to because
because it seems like none of this is a
big deal you know there's more for fast
bagging I'm just teasing fast me he
knows what I'm doing right it's not for
a team it's really for fast man it's out
the fastbacks out the LG you know mug
you might do is I'm just playing games
right now but devil's advocate like what
does it take for you to say yo I am
concerned because it seems like none of
this bothers guys or that kid I'm just
curious
I just think that people do get ahead of
themselves
now I've people that are I know that are
generally concerned I am like cool man
like you know you're concerned cuz you
know probably one of the head people is
leaving the company you got demoted he
randomly left that could be see that the
demoted part makes me less concerned
because it feels like more of an eternal
thing and not like it's like like a
development thing like you know he could
have done anything this you could have
been caught with hookers like like
anything that would cause the studio get
demoted could have happened and then he
left because of the demotion
that's what would I see on it like we
don't know if it was we don't know if it
was you know like like anchorman could
have been family related like he took
the demotion cuz he couldn't to dedicate
more time and then you know things got
to the point where he couldn't even
dedicate the time he had their suite
left the company like it could be a
variety of different things my question
my question to you attics steel stairs
when do you actually get concerned
because I'm not saying you can't be
concerned
now I'm just saying that there's too
much forget forget this specific one
right but give me a scenario where you
actually get concerned before launch
about a game whether it be people
leaving or what do you need to hear to
get you concerned I would never get
concerned over one personally it would
be a group of people leaving so like
what it's like abandon ship so would you
would you have been concerned if Cory
bar log left nine months before release
but that doesn't that's a different
scenario that's the creative director
but that's like equivalent a Barney Ross
leaving when he created her out it is
he's creative director but he's head of
that studio too it is it is this isn't
Barney Ross head of the studio five
hours into Hobbit of you know the story
status direction of Halo Infinite I'll
wait you're absolutely right fully who
are you absolutely I think I can tell
you I'm telling you all I'm telling you
right now is that for this particular
scenario there is just too many
variables we don't know right well he
could have got demoted for anything 100%
right my reason for worrying is that
halo Infinite has a lot more riding on
its shoulders and just regular Halo game
it is the hail is poster is this is
chief swans why this is it right the
ship right it's oast to help the scarlet
launch in a positive way if this game
fails out of the box poor game scarlet
goes with it right at least the
narrative overseas so you thought you
saved a lot more riding on it adjust
halo oh but I get that but at the same
time it's like from this one person
leaving that got demoted we can't say
the whole games in development like
we've seen bad when I had gameplay of
the game we have to see nothing like I
don't know know anything if if it would
have been like me people saw crackdown
we had concern for cracked out for
reasons
there's so many years into the
development time they were working they
didn't start a new engine like three
four three they didn't do none of that
like for the most part we've seen
nothing but positivity on halo every
time it's come up you know we seem good
stuff although everybody chat all not
concerned about the game because it's
not on me to be so hits on Microsoft
when 343 need to be concerned at that
game impresses me as a consumer because
there's plenty of other games out there
so he's got it going too soft point
which is there's a lot of pressure on
this halo it's a launch title for
scarlet there's a lot riding time the
time that you would be worried is that
they show you solid gameplay and it's
not looking good okay like that's when
you should be worried when you have no
actual physical proof there's something
wrong in this chat and in this Google
hangout and you got demoted tomorrow you
will be okay that's the other point too
I think you agree this is the fact that
he had the job for a couple of weeks
where's like if I if I got demoted like
seriously devoted for something I did
wrong
I'm not staying I'm out attic so Regis
[Music]
get you back in the first all these
people are talking long since its second
or third they see coloring that [ __ ]
they save everything in nine months out
it is the 11th hour Russian it is not
it's not like there's five or six people
leaving its once incident in the entire
development cycle is the dude is in
charge of the entire business I don't
mean nothing
I don't know you're the one that said
you're walking away from hey love the
story the foundation for the games been
built he leaving South College K
devastate this game you agree with that
that it's whether he looks now and
leaving wouldn't look at the game if the
game is trash as he was responsible
regardless if he's there or not cuz he
was there he built the foundation he
built the foundation the games upon now
I would say you would want to blame
Barney Ross too because she would she
was over him but at the same time look
this if this games could be good at this
game is gonna be bad him leaving has
nothing to do with the games already
wrap into chat hoodie Wow $20 super chef
thank you brother it's eye-opening
because the creative director left and
an executive producer left less than a
year before the game has to go Gold is
the game don't know but best believe
that 343 is gonna crunch OH crotch
clutch clutch Oh is that's what's going
on here man but at the end of the day
this dude leaving isn't gonna impact the
final product sure it might be a reason
these people are leaving but we don't
know like when we get that final product
if it's a 69 there's probably reason he
got demoted and they probably just
flushed the entire company down the
joint yet your home might mantra is less
weight let's see gameplay yeah but with
you if we saw a play like the crackdown
scenario everyone knew that game was
gonna be a dumpster fire right because
we had plenty of proof to say that it
was a dumpster fire but one person get
demoted and leaving a company it's not
enough to to validate that this game go
be spooky man I don't know what's going
on look like it's concerning but it's
not enough concern to be like there's
something really wrong like it would
have been different if like this dude
left and this dude got posted and this
dude's doing this and this dude's with
this person and and but it's not that
someone got demoted and they quit and I
and I guarantee you if you look at
people in that
position or throughout every industry
and they get to motive a lot of them
probably leave very shortly after
getting demoted mmm real quick JD
gheymeh again thank you brother to file
out super chat they have over 12 months
to fix it it will be fine as long as the
game goes gold by September 2020 it will
be it's not 12 months like they have
like in realistically they got like nine
to ten months and that's pushing it I
would say eight to nine months because
the the last couple months is literally
strictly just you know complete
going to just fixing bugs playing
getting the game played over and over
again to make sure it doesn't crash they
got the certification you can make fun
that's bouncing right off the JD game
one they have over 12 months to fix a JD
a job yeah really letting that except
y'all down he turned with the balls on
Lord's Day the whole panel got a little
sight when he raised his voice you know
what you know what I don't listen I'm
the one I'm very I'm a skeptical person
I'm saying when I see things and I'm
just like oh how does it feel what's the
what's the perception right what's the
optics does it feel right with Halo
Infinite close to launch right but then
as you read more and you look into it
and then they say they seem like they
already had a replacement in Pocket
right so again back to my selfish point
I don't like halophiles campaign if he's
responsible Bush's I don't want him part
of it he doesn't but my whole thing is
to addicts points we do need to see the
game when we see the reveal if we start
to see that quality degradation and we
desire
what's going on I'm working in Iran I do
get this I'm in the middle you always
like I'm more concerned at the direction
of halos going and you know what this
too might have been responsible for that
like I got to see more like I all we've
really seen is it looks like two minutes
at the beginning of the very beginning
of the game and we've seen an in-game
engine showing off the game like what
the game could possibly look like until
I see more right like it's kind of bad
right it looks bad on there because it's
been how long we know he's always I got
this Eric's on fire right now this is
what I'm talking like he says tell y'all
what though --if halo Infinite is it
poppin y'all gonna get all the smoke and
then that's when the people get if halo
5 is not popping and narrative Lee is
trashed then the people who were
concerned will be justified to come out
y'all to be like yo this is why we was
upset I see that but I'm calling
[ __ ] on that too I'm not saying that
you can't come I'm not saying that you
can't come at people for saying that I'm
saying that we need more than just this
I get I go back to my overall point
regardless of whether this is justified
or not or worrying or not worried about
it the fact matter is that the game has
more riding on it than just halo it's as
gallant the entire next generation
riding on its shoulders and even if the
game is hot but for whatever reason this
change in management makes the game be
um delayed I think a delay even hurts
them a delay even hurts them because
they already came out and said this is
looking with the next system Philly
Philly in the chase yeah hypocrites
yeah show something too early to late
y'all what's the spot well I tell you
one thing for years early is not a good
idea I mean why is it concerning yes
but I don't think
it's like I don't think there's Hellfire
rainy don't look outside to make sure
nobody's saying that but you're like
you're you just saying that it's nothing
I'm not saying it's nothing I'm saying
for one incident you can't deem the
entire project as all do I don't know
about this because that's what you actin
like guys now what is not putting words
that sir oh no I am putting about I am
putting on play music this game has
everything riding on it and this makes
it worse
cuz this part make it worse like it was
I might make it a little concerning why
did you leave but like I said at the end
of the day when you would you ask okay
why'd you leave you don't know it could
be multiple if this to just like always
ever you speaking black or white I never
said anything black or white I said it's
spooky and why it's spooky and it's
spooky because again it's not just like
regular halo game it is a reboot
essentially a surger reboot it's high
halo franchise the future of the Halo
franchise is riding on it in addition to
the success of the Scala platform you
understand it's just reason to look at
it with a side eye I'm not saying that
it's gloom and doom and it's all over
but using this change means that the
game for whatever reason gets delayed
and the thing is we go and see but I
will say for the people who feel right
now that this is not a concern right
that this is not a big deal if this
happens a lot and I understand the
sentiment
all we got is all I'm saying is if it
does prove that halo 5 I mean halo
Infinite is spooky narrative Lee or a
launch this will be used against y'all
and then they're gonna people will say
you can't get mad at us for being
skeptical that's all people come at me
on Twitter they can get that block a
mute button it's like look I don't see
it's concerning if you want to come at
me a year from now because I made an
opinion
off the fire the facts in the
information in front of me I'm with my
uncle blue on the Block in mutual eyes
because anyways you are even taking the
consideration that from what we have now
me personally that's not your opinion
that's my opinion and if you want to
harass me on Twitter for my opinion you
will get muted there's no way around you
will get me to rap with the Fonz Alice's
attack in fairness this is under the
microscope because how bad Microsoft
first party has been this generation
very true your duty you guys are try to
meet a drink departures got to keep the
theme consistent man we got to two big
announcements on one actually just
recently you know I'm saying with
Dragons age four and again this is a
lead producer Fernando Mello and I'm
saying acted as a senior producer for
dragons orange and dragons age two is is
leaving man he has moving on Elm he's
not gonna be part of the new Dragon Age
experience and then prior to that anthem
anthem was hit again man Ben
Irving another lead producer he was part
of the team that was left I know a lot
of them went over to dragons age like
Mark Darin them guys but uh yeah Ben all
he was still there you know holding the
fort down and um yeah he's now leaving
he's moving on looks like um she said
he's going to another studio but the
game has still has a bright future you
know a lot of people to watch you show
up an initiative that like you don't
have a super chat okay get this super
check into some chat so we got the $5
super chat oh no there's another one but
let me let me get to you first year from
true Kingdom I probably put your name I
apologize the creative directors out
because Microsoft wants to bring back
sparked all right man
dedicated $5.00 a week we appreciate
appreciate the support
do it do it mike colter needs a job Luke
AIDS anymore Oh another $5 to perch at
from basement radio arcade podcast halo
infinite will work at launch
unlike fallout how do you feel about
that anchorman waiting you know about
that I don't need to address that okay
got you like continued continued we got
major producer Khanna departures kind of
in succession you know I'm saying one
with anthem you know and then the our
sea dragons age which was the latest one
souls I just wanna bring us to the
Lord's men like what how are we feeling
about Bioware right now all we fear
monger is this is nothing to be
concerned about to be honest with you
after anthem
I think Bioware in jeroni just be thrown
in the bushes unlike Halo infinite I see
anthem it exists I swear it's unlike
Halo infinite we've played anthem I seen
it we've played it so yes I would say
[Laughter]
what do you do sir for all dragons age
now leaves and then by where you don't
bleed off anthem in its current state
you don't leave like where you at with
both of these departures I seem to
recall a couple months ago they were
talking about ever ever since anthem
kind of bomb which is kind of sad bomb
is the correct term I like I think the
only other game that has bomb Mors
follow 76 they don't know Mass Effect
Andromeda sir oh I see
no I think this is worse than I expected
Ravi why people weren't coming at
followed 76 for character animations and
do fall at 76 ruined the whole company
made it to a Bethesda had to go on there
III stage and personally apologize to
the game okay at least they apologize
Bioware in trouble as we do it I would
definitely say so namely because ever
since anthem came out why they have been
said they said they were restructuring
how Dragon Age was gonna be approached
they they kept saying everything's
changing because they've released two
games now whether or not you say oh yeah
I was a Montreal team or not it's two
games under the Bioware name that have
bombed in a row Mass Effect Andromeda
which came out two years ago and then
you have anthem which came out and so
now it's just what do you do like things
are definitely good to be restructuring
man I don't know what else to tell you
about it it's just there's not much else
to say so do you think it's a situation
let's break it down individually with
anthem you know a lot of people have
called out by where and said look you
know you guys are leaving this game for
dead a lot of that the bigger higher ups
have gone over the Dragons age for shout
to slow mo yeah who's literally just say
what about to say mark taro who took
over for Ben Hur everyone anthem got the
game release is still in charge of
Dragon 84 and Mark dar was involved in
all the previous Japanese game so a lot
of them have moved on to dragons Asian
anthems case right but then arvind was
there and then they are the I guess the
live team so with him moving off of
anthem let's go anthem first do you
think anthem this is kind of like a
death knell for them that they're moving
away from supporting me I am Not sure
about it what it means for anthem
necessarily I mean because it's a
producer right but I for all that for
future games I think it's definitely a
big sign okay and then with dragons age
specifically
again another producer are you not as
concerned because you know there's more
concern I'm working okay because the
Dragons age that game there's so much
uncertainty about that about whether or
not it what it could even look like is
the biggest concern like people talked
about how Oh dragon age inquisition came
out and that was good i did not so well
I'm not sure because I remember before
the game of the Year announcement before
that they were announcing it was
terrible sales I remember before example
we were doing it we were in a party
chairman out right before the event with
a hood everyone butts off we were
talking about that was it was it was a I
think that call a 76 them then from your
place years ago though
let me see back then and it said they
said it was performing well under
expectations before every date it allows
it all right there was an earnings call
on 2015 that said that Inquisition was
the most successful launch and Bioware's
history right right okay now the funny
thing is that when they talked about the
numbers they pull the Microsoft and he
started changing how they address this
stuff it didn't sales numbers they
talked about number of hours spent in
the game yes inquisitors questions since
I always come through it's probably the
biggest Bioware supporter I can see wow
that Bioware's in trouble if they don't
overall they're like hold on we got
stopped because shots my man Phil ego he
is
the biggest Anthem fan he's the biggest
buy for him to say this got it was
Madison all I know is from day one I was
saying it's not looking good over there
and Bauer in anthem land and when antha
came out people attacked me hardcore you
please point and that goes into what I
was gonna say about this if they don't
overhaul they're done and I think as
spooky as this looks the fact that
Cataclysm dropped didn't do well we've
created director Wolf's way some people
things arise some people think that for
how long they had to wait for it it
wasn't enough and you know so it's it's
up in the air some people like it some
people don't as long as they're getting
content I guess some people be happy but
I think the fact that they're looked at
Dragon Age whatever Dragon Age was
turning into and they decided to there
was a move made now as it's spooky
because that tells you that this is
Bioware his last shot what I do like
about it is that they did it early yeah
you know cuz the game that games the
next gen game regardless what that game
is a 2022 game probably no I said I just
think I think I'm glad they did it early
it's spooky that they that they needed
to address that this early because it
means that it really is sort of their
last hurrah like if they don't get
listen man I wish King was here cuz he
is a song things are going like it's the
people you latch on to when you were
younger they change people people become
has been Oh
I don't I don't like be on the left side
of the ship with anchorman sometimes the
magic is lost
we got people we got people that can't
even make an 80s metacritic game now we
got a Microsoft studio that deserves to
be a Microsoft right now we're gonna do
here's the deal here's the deal
all right in my opinion you know say it
could be just a situation where it's
just not the same people anymore
people move on Studios changed you know
say in in Vilas case and just like it's
sad because we know what they were they
were top three you know of everybody's
development less you know it's kind of
crazy like they would them do right so I
guess you know again another part of it
is what I'm hearing what and so
specifically you know shout the part i
see maytee box we had him on the last
word please check that out just lastly
even if you like that please check that
was a fantastic episode but um he
mentioned how like the Cataclysm is so
good low-key he's saying anthem is
better Division two right now and that's
one of his hottest takes right now that
a lot of people are some people are
actually riding with him a lot of anthem
fan shot the kibosh there's people
saying yo it's really good so the
question went with Irving you know I'm
saying I'm not gonna try to act like he
was a saint down in all the decisions
because he made some orangy decisions
that pissed the community off on some
levels and things like that but you know
in terms of Bioware is just I am very
concerned I'm very concerned and I'm
saying we got to see where this thing is
gonna go and dragons age like like soft
said everything's riding on dragons age
everything you don't wanna like put it
this way if Dragon Age flop that will be
Mass Effect Andromeda anthem now anthem
yes MPD is up there but as far as
engagement we know it ain't where it was
you don't say they might see that as a W
just because of the sales but I don't
think
I don't think ei sees the game those
games are slow steams are not built on
their initial sales they built on the
returning right base if you were buying
it and buying microtransaction I know
there's no discord in Fisher statement
no I agree with anchor cuz I was just
saying like even though we look at it
and we say yo anthem number for NPD
right for all for 2019
EA's had other expectations for where
this thing was supposed to be they are
not expecting this planet count to be
where it is they expecting this thing to
continue to go so my thing is you know I
just want Dragon Age leave the windrow
road but it is it that anthems win is
based on like like it like Anka said and
this is a game that that's focused on
like the combat raid whatever that stuff
that stuff needs to be there for that
that community to stay there what
meaning for me and I think in general
for Bioware fan if that story stuff is
not where it needs to be dragon because
that's the essence yeah yes that's what
people go to Bioware for dialogue no and
that's why anthem also struggle because
people thought they were gonna get
classic by we're in a destiny format
right man and then we got limited
choices we didn't really get that kind
of engagement so Dragons age is like the
last hurrah but I will say this like a
dragon's age flop throw out the e8 they
are they go snap them out of existence
wrong I don't think that there's an
entity that's going on that no one's
really thinking about talking Bethesda
sometimes you need a variable to happen
to show that you're doing things wrong
mm-hmm
you know obviously they've had countless
failures over and over again I do te a
had a lot to do with a lot of these
reaching now I think Bioware is
responsible too people will always try
to blame the publisher when it's
sometimes it's the developer just as
much but I think a lot of us to do with
not necess
Sara Lee how Bioware's ran as a company
but the direction that ei makes the run
as a company right so I think that
people aren't really good like they're
starting to give respawn more you know
creative control maybe if the last what
would life Jedi what is a cone um fallen
or did I fall in order maybe if that
comes out and it's a it's like a crazy
hit makes all kinds of money maybe that
was she sings like okay you know we got
multiplayer games that we can make money
off of but these people like Bioware
your response we gotta let them do what
they want to do but you know by we're in
all if it wasn't Bioware it would have
been shut down two games ago but because
they have so much clout because of what
they've done in the past they're able to
make another game there's very few
publishers that let them make a third
game okay it would have been like a lot
of publishers would it Microsoft would
have shut them down over Mass Effect
Sony would have shut them down over
anthem Y EA I feel like EA they know
that but they can do something like
maybe I don't think they I don't think
Dragon Age flops like they have a good
formula there unless they do something
crazy different I don't I don't think
that can flop like you know in Dragon
Age they haven't really made a bad
Dragon Age game there's people you know
people didn't really like a lot of the
directions hold on one sec soft turn in
early Dragon Age talk about destiny with
dragons then we hear some creative
vision for the new era that they're
trying to include other features that
really weren't part of it I think people
were fearful of that after it felt like
they were all in on the anthem type of
game and they had to come out and sort
of reiterate be like no it's a it's a
Dragon Age game so they had to say like
there's aren't gonna be loot boxes in
this thing they are it's gonna be an R
so they had to come out and just sort of
defend what a Dragon Age game is just so
people would it out you know discard
discount the game right from the jump
once they announced it so and that's
what they did in slow mo said if I'm bar
where I'm looking at EA
different treatment of respawn and be
like why TF are they being treated
different apex legend is using the
titanfall engine and following orders
using unreal I think that respawn went
in there and when they were getting
bargaining with their companies they had
a lot more to go off of them by the way
I feel when you come in off of two fell
games you can't really negotiate that's
the thing though cuz you you look at the
development of Andromeda right Andromeda
regardless of you know EAS meddling
whatever whatever was going on and
turned internally in terms of the the
studio that made that game not be great
the fact the matter is that they still
if they were still making a Mass Effect
game they still had the choices it's
just the game wasn't nearly as good as
the three previous but they were allowed
to make a Mass Effect game right like
they tried to change that formula true
but but two addicts point is that
respawn I feel had a little bit more
capital coming in with the titanfall
franchise right yeah and it had the
critical success of two games critical
success I did 8x
I think respawn probably I don't know
you know the individual people but I
think they can be Yoona Kate with da
better I think they are for the most
part it looks like I don't know like
obviously I'm not behind closed doors
but to me it seems like cut because
respawn gets what they want maybe it's
just you know it really is a Bioware
issue may be eaten maybe just those that
how to present their project better to
make one also a great defense of Jason
Schreyer Whitney someone woman named
somebody was snitching at Bioware saying
what was going on and how flying was so
last minute people meetings were like it
was a mess racist Bioware like it wasn't
EA as far as the grenade they broke down
and anthems development I was shocked to
see how many poor decisions and how many
lack of planning and very lazy fair very
relaxed all will get to it and no no
resolution at the end of meetings it was
really spooky
coming from Bioware not give it to
Brooke like Philly Eagle files which I
if no man sky could come back any game
can come back but that is true that that
is
that's what your I think if respawns
you know I know we're going away from
Bioware for for a brief second I think
of respawn makes this game that they're
not only one of EA's best to you if
their best to you I think they're one of
the best developers in the industry
right now like bye-bye we're went from
probably one of the goats like one of
the top ever to like to like I know
Cognito is gonna really hate this
analogy he went to like an Anderson
Silva like like you know he's still good
no I would say Anders I would say the
comparison on UFC Anderson silver so
better than Bioware is before they were
like cuz cuz I by were just they're just
not making good games anymore like you
know you can blame EA you can boy I
think the the core example I think where
it needs to be looked at is the head of
Bioware they're the ones droppin the
ball I think Jays influences have
something to do with it but I would say
it's like 8020 80% Bioware's fault 20%
yeas fault I think it's a lot of EA's
fault for not maintaining and making
sure Bioware's management's doing stuff
they need to be doing it's a tough
scenario man Wow just you know news
keeps piling on we got to move on cuz we
got like a couple more topics but um
yeah man arts off hold on real quick
it's less whoa last one on this this is
funny slow-mo he said and the dude who
is running that BS show on what you
gonna is now going over to Dragon sayst
reading Peter and Wow I'm just saying
better believe it is an addition by
subtraction Wow
moving on Lord so there is a lot of talk
in these streets about Microsoft yeah
recently uh head of Xbox game studios
Matt booty booty booty times we don't go
down like this you know that right well
you don't have to emphasize booty every
time you fill still give up the booty
call or two it
oh yeah yeah been ever left by where
he's not on dragons he you correct sir
I'm correct you're correct continue bad
booty had an interview with a game of
war magazine where they talked about uh
you know what's coming up in terms of
game past the future of scarlet they
talked a little bit about Halo Infinite
and you know just basically kind of gave
a little bit of a roadmap of what's
going on with the Xbox platform and
ecosystem so one thing that came up that
had the internet even the side-eye is
they spoke about specific games that are
appearing on other platforms they spoke
about cuphead on switch and minecraft
obviously and they talked about how you
know Microsoft's new new sort of vision
for the future where you know up not
that they're gonna be platform agnostic
but they're more willing to see their
their their ecosystem is just that an
ecosystem not necessarily tied 100% to a
specific platform so they asked what
other games could you expect or if any
to see from Microsoft from Xbox Studios
on other platforms
so obviously this started the
conversation that Microsoft is opening
up to having all of their games on other
platforms and that this is the
beginnings of them trying to slip in
talk of essentially not caring about
platform and may be happy if franchises
on PlayStation on Nintendo on PC and
obviously there was a lot of heated
discussion around this so I wanna know
what guys think about this
he spoke about I said he spoke about
cuphead he spoke about Minecraft and how
that was you know that was a no brainer
because that was already on other
platforms and it just makes sense for
what they wanted to do with Minecraft
they didn't want to remove anybody's
ability to play that game um and but
again they're they're doing it with
Minecraft dungeons which they didn't
have to do Oh
once again it's gonna be on every
platform as aníbal um and it so he sort
of left the door open for anything's
possible not necessarily our big 10th
hole games
we hope you know that the Big Mac drives
in the coke that's not happening at
least for now
he sort of phrased that so what do you
guys think about this it's just
fear-mongering is this them trying to
start that conversation so we're not
totally surprised in a couple of years
when it happens what are you guys okay
go for Valley eachother did we get a
good
are you stones give me someone just
walked in my room overreacting well a
couple things to bring up so looking at
cuphead and minecraft
cuphead I don't they say it's a
Microsoft game I don't think that was
part of the deal and I think they just
have they're trying to play that out
they're trying to be like oh yeah we're
constraining who's getting on what but
really the deal is just not allowed to
go to PlayStation just let everybody
else kind of fly but minecraft that's a
again another weird scenario because
I've already brought up that thing
already came out on PlayStation before
Microsoft bought minecraft so they were
in a position where they couldn't really
just drop support looking looking and
looking like a dick or that that is a
situation other than that with their
options I mean there they you have to
keep in mind what Matt booties job is
Matt booty his job is to sell the games
right his job is not to sell the
platform his job and if you keep teasing
people that is good it does it make sure
you don't lock it out of your mind
for example I would swish as long as I
don't show the best example but like
when LeBron was looking every signing
yeah whether I was gonna stay with the
Cavs are gonna outlay or wherever else
he never said I'm not going to this
place right he never said that
by Susan
it was her that he was up for discussion
everybody wanted him right and so but
things also fans who hated LeBron
because he was not on their team
suddenly were like oh wait
LeBron come here the pelicans gonna come
the Clippers everybody suddenly wants
him because that is the same mindset
when it comes to games too if you tease
them and don't say it's never coming out
here because that that's where the
problems that happens whether you have a
Saudi games Nintendo games not like that
where people know it's never coming
right to their platform of choice or
whatever else they say after that game
I'm not paying attention it's trash and
the bushes never thinking about it again
but he teased them you like it it could
come
it could come maybe the point of
contention on social media the fact that
the mission statement was initially Xbox
doesn't have games we have to address
this we're getting these Studios right
that was the mission statement to
address the Achilles heel in the room so
to speak so now that they have these
studios right when you hear talk of well
maybe these games can come out on other
platforms does that concern you because
some the talk from some is well what's
the point of having these studios if you
just gonna put them games or everybody
else's platform exactly it would be a
tipple a studio or not like right I to
me I don't care that game I don't care
I'm retired
it's it to me I don't care but again
people have to look at it from a
business perspective if you burn your
bridges you're done people don't care
anymore
this is this is why these changes in
these studio changes so
we mean something like tim schafer being
bought for Microsoft when he had been
talking so much ever since the beginning
of this generation either talking so
much junk to see oh wait never mind the
money's here never mind
so Wilson about that because this is one
thing that we never really got clarity
on it's like oh not to officially just a
Microsoft exclusive for exactly it's
it's the second our students still
coming up every platform because it's
already promised everywhere just future
stuff so that's a that's a thing because
they never they show it's like the
announce Psychonauts to in sony stage
and they're not pulling that back I
think that they are trying to do what
they did with the with Xbox Live and
going to the digital air where
everyone's online like to try and
anticipate a market that might be there
might not necessarily be there now you
know if you went before Xbox Live blew
up and for Sony to really adapt to an
online community what before all that
happened and said yo everyone's gonna be
playing in parties you were playing call
of duty
would you have what would you have
thought that no I mean do I think this
is a mistake
I think they're investing too much into
this that might not necessarily happen
because what they want is they think
streaming they want to anticipate the
streaming market that's what they're
doing like they're trying to get
themselves to where it's all about an
app and not a console uh I think that's
going to happen just not anytime soon
but you know if it's one of those things
worse I'm like a 50/50 like I feel like
they're they're really risking a lot
like this is one of those things where
if this doesn't pill out they might sell
the Xbox Brian oh oh because I mean they
are that they're putting a lot they're
putting a lot behind this like they are
like if it doesn't work out I don't
think it is because I think game paths
is going to help to tremendously you
know game pass I think eventually is
going to be
in to that xbox act you know but at the
end of the day it's like if they try
it's like 2013 people thought that was
the wrong direction when added up
happening we have all these online
connected games literally what if they
had said happen happen five years later
you make you you got me thinking what
about the counterpoint which is
PlayStation does not operate this way
PlayStation when they have when Sony has
their exclusive there's never an
executive coming out and saying well at
some point you know we may consider you
know death training or another platform
or we make a sin of God what if it makes
sense like we don't hear the other day
now what is your answer to their way of
thinking and handling the videogames
business and exclusivity as opposed to
Microsoft oh is it you stop it at you
think that Sony the business is so
riding on the game industry that's why I
think that is I think that they they
have that one mindset right now I mean I
know their movie divisions doing good
but like besides that it's only really
bringing revenue piece up with any other
division besides the gaming division
like so Microsoft's got their hands in
so many cookie jars and you know someday
throw the cookie away like the mobile
biz division I I think somebody's
perceived strength comes from them being
the antithesis to Microsoft like right
then being the opposite of what
Microsoft is doing this is the thing I'm
looking at as I say if you want an idea
of what I'm talking about where if you
burn your bridges you turn people off
from ever being customers to you go look
at the worst people in our community if
you don't look at the worst Xbox people
they say screw every Sony game because
they know it's not coming they can't be
excited for it right because they know
they're never gonna get to play it so
they mind mentally shuts that shuts it
off says I don't care right but so ever
situations do happen where a PlayStation
game that was thought to be exclusive
does come back special males
it'll buy it they don't want it done
they're mentally they made it turned off
for example the witness by Jonathan Blow
he came out and getting the duration
talked a bunch of crap
then ya been witness comes to xbox three
years later Noah wants it because of you
turn people off from it then on the flip
side look at the worst Sony people
anytime there's a new game that comes
out for PlayStation they rub it in their
face Xbox guys you're never gonna be to
play this but what a new game comes up
the Xbox they want right then the
question becomes when's it coming to
PlayStation I think at the end of the
day Microsoft they they're anticipating
you know they when it comes to these
multi-billion dollar corporations like
they're not looking for now like they're
looking at like ten years for now that's
one of the reasons that I think that bag
sparks brand is where it is is because
there was a time where they didn't know
what they were doing with Xbox they
didn't know what to invest and they
didn't know what you and Philips mature
putting game pass in the scenario I
don't know who started that almost gave
the idea but I think they're all right
now we know what we want with the Xbox
burn we want to revolve around game
paths right and I think that was a press
solely say the entire brain well I mean
you're making a good point from the
sense addict atom that was the pitch to
Sachi from Phil right because we know
I'm not gonna try disrespect Sasha but
it's like video games is not his forte
they were during the time Terry Myerson
thing they were still floundering as far
as how much the Xbox brand means to the
overall picture right Phil gets the
position and then is selling them also
on the game plastic services and stuff
like that and basically I want to shout
out the Xbox too can add a good
discussion on this recently basically
Phil's pitch was are we in on video
games are we not if we're in on video
games we got to go all in on video games
thus he got the promotion and thus we're
seeing what's happening now with the
commitment to the studios and more of a
serious push but prior to that it was
not they were still that you know so
saachi's whole thing is he speaks he's
got to be to the state let me get in on
point he's got to speak to this to the
stockholders right
like is it valuable for them to consider
Microsoft Xbox you know investing on
that level so Phil kinda has this this
tough line he has to walk my thing is
this
when I hear booties comments right I'm
with solve I listen to what someone's
telling me with someone's telling me
well it may be it depends it's a case by
case you know that's how I'm looking at
I think they're looking at it not like
the typical acquisition thing where when
you acquire studio it's yours it's only
on your platform that's it they're
looking at it like yo if it makes sense
like a cup head or whatever you look a
bit good be good on switch and minecraft
it's so big you see it's on Sony's
platform I believe it was like oh but
number two number three on NPD for Sony
just recently you know on Sam
so yeah they're going to do it you know
that so my thing is I think mentally if
you're a hardcore Xbox guy you better
prepare yourself I just that's just what
I did to me they are telling us what
could happen now again this is the
question and this what I'm gonna bring
the addict and anchor games like a hell
blade to number he'll blaze started
initially Sony right yeah boom now we
know eventually it will come those games
to me are candidates for this strategy
well we might we don't want to you know
we could make some more money you know
it being open in the PlayStation Bay
same thing without a Wyles obsidian
excuse me obsidian already announced the
switch version right Playstations
getting but we knew that was before the
deal so a lot of Xbox guys like that
slide that's before to do right but
again if it blows up on those platforms
you mean to tell me that Microsoft is
gonna say let's keep it exclusive
you know that's one of the things that
you know a cute older people would like
look like that's why I said that they're
you know they're putting a lot of what's
what I'm looking for faith into this
strategy right because if it doesn't
work out they devalue their brands uh
you know now it's not Xbox got these
games outlets you could play it
everywhere why do I need a console and
before you know it that because of the
do
they went and if it didn't work out then
you know before you know it they're
getting out of the console business
because they devalued the console so
much that no one wants to buy it but you
can buy most to buy their games on the
BSE I feel you but if they are continued
to be financially this is a great
strategy for I'm financing they're
making revenue well the different
scenario I said if it doesn't work okay
oh god gives you saying so you said if
it don't work then people go how do we
know that we get to the point where you
know they start Frenchie cuz I think
Sony's the last pillar well I think I
don't I think Microsoft is very capable
of putting their stuff on Sony's
platform I think there's a lot of
fairies behind that I don't think
Microsoft's ready to have that
conversation entirely with everything
maybe stuff like you know
cuphead stuff like that would you know
cup it it's kind of weird that on there
already but it's almost that's the
completely different that did that deal
be anybody but Sony I think I think you
know it's very possible that it could
happen and I think once you start seeing
Microsoft games have been on the console
on the PlayStation how do we know that
they start making revenue everywhere
else but the Xbox console and then they
it they literally become a third party
and they pull out of the console
business like it's very possible like
right on down a road this is the thing
right I don't know if you look at the
studio acquisitions and what they put
together right the only studios that
seem like they're big triple a or
quadruple a Studios are the initiative
and the second studio coming out of take
two or turn whatever the the fable
studio I think I'm sitting at the place
to do about the games particularly the
games that are coming out what they're
looking to make right so let's say they
assume that the ones that we're looking
at and seem like they're big studios in
line with the 343 in line with the
coalition stuff like that you would say
is the initiative and and the fable
studio they did that don't you
playground exactly Kraig's aren't
putting together other than that right
everyone else we don't know what's
coming down the pipeline but it's been
assumed by based on what they've made
before these aren't the hugest game
right so looking at what he said the
games that he's saying could possibly be
on other platforms would make you think
that the majority of their portfolio is
open to that strategy of a heart from
whatever they consider to be pillars and
he mentioned forza he more it's
mentioned halo he mentioned gears and
the only other two you could maybe add
to that would be those two that I
mentioned those two big ones beyond that
I it will bothers me a little bit it's
just it doesn't feel like everything
that they've acquired to now they're not
considering them pillar titles they're
not considering them pillar studio you
might kind of like these are these like
I don't think they can really consider
anything a pillar until they show
product like you you know once if you
start building because they they didn't
just buy the studio they've actually put
money into the studio on top of that
right yeah you know so what I think
before they go out and they really start
bragging about these studios or having
any kind of wording on them like they
gotta show us some kind of qualities
like obsidian I think a lot of people
don't really look at you know they're
like outer world this outer words that
it's a multi flight at the end of the
day our work still shows the result of
kind of quality that we can expect we
have Cydia
and they said specifically the outer
worlds they said that we could see it as
being fully exclusive moving forward and
that's all depending on how well other
worlds does right let me I'll say Lee if
you guys pay attention the film industry
you you would know that in terms of how
a lot of the stuff is budgeted and
approached models are very similar to
how the video game industry is nowadays
but it's a there's a mark of everything
that week's moving so there's a concept
of like a tentpole movie it comes out
during the summer make a big blockbuster
or whatever however that the movie
industry has moved away from that right
is they're just having one movie that
makes or breaks your studio right you
have multiple bigger movies that could
survive like for example use Disney as
an example if when Dumbo came out and
failed comparatively Lion King
and just everything else was there to
pick up the slack the idea is that you
can survive if one if one thing bomb no
I grata gee I get it my question in
terms of video games is the same kind of
thing where like if you have one game
and that game bombs right you're not out
of business
it's a risky baby you make a valid point
say you're on fire I guess my point is
what no Russian is a so I'll have to
know Russia to philony they battle it in
the chat right now it's lit he's saying
that you know because their Xbox like
the heat feels that the gaming device is
being devalued like what made us invest
in Xbox in the first place if they're
gonna approach a strategy of hey these
game studios that we bought not saying
every game like solve is saying like you
know but not sorry saying that but solve
is making a point that they're trying to
say that you know the Big Mac Lord
Frey's shake halo for the gears that
probably most likely is not but if these
new studios that people were genuinely
excited about right people were very
excited like yo Xbox gonna have some
exclusive it's gonna be on their
platform people are saying what do you
say to the people saying you know that
is now being devalue what is the purpose
of owning the Xbox platform the game
past is such a major part for them like
their positioning and everything has
pushed game past to the point where that
is a seller in and of itself my
girlfriend has been going back and forth
about what what platform she wants to
get because you once he went out of
their cheap and what she wants to play
is she wants to play Kingdom Hearts 3
okay she wants to play persona 5 but she
doesn't got the money for it for a lot
of stuff and so then it's like well let
me make a game pass was game pass so we
go through this whole thing about yeah
well you pay ten bucks a month or you
just pay fifteen and you get it on PC
and you got an xbox and you get play
online you play all those games you can
buy Kingdom Hearts 3 and you're done but
you get a ton of other games you aren't
really necessarily interested in or
couldn't afford included right what
about some of those games out here
and that that value alone sells the
console right so so is this a thing
where let me say let me tell me come and
talk slanderous right now all the
hardcore guys are they are they going to
be extinct or they're not there their
way of thinking is it an antiquated way
of thinking to be upset at Microsoft for
doing putting these Xbox games through
your quote-unquote supposedly exclusives
on other platforms Oh everybody is
stationary every single one of these
people who are still stuck in this
mindset of exclusives and platform sales
and the next 10 day five years may be
able to make that argument so it solves
point right where are they setting us up
for how inadequate they say for the next
generation of hottest people people
forget the first person out there
talking about the future of the gen
after this of the ninth gym the first
person out there talking about putting
games no stuff on comm platforms was not
Phil Spencer
it was Shuhei Yoshida 2013 there was an
article that came out it was about a
month before the next the PlayStation 4
dropped the I I remember it distinctly
cuz I was back at unc-asheville walking
back on reading the article and they're
talking about like I see the sad to see
the future of PlayStation being like an
app where you have all your games you
just play it wherever you want and
everyone's like yeah yeah whatever you
already already owned Xbox we're not
gonna pay attention to this all right
people move on you shout out to JD game
with the file a super chat I think the
pillars studios are 343 coalition turn
10 playground studios I don't know what
1 & 2 is but um of city or maybe he's
been talking about a timetable for the
yeah um obsidian ninja Siri and he
mentioned state of the case undead labs
and you know we I want to point out that
Microsoft loves changing their mind for
all I know
outer world comes out it's like a 8687
sells millions of copies and then before
you know it they're like ok you know
maybe our fans are right maybe games can
so consoles well let's go back to the
drawing board but maybe we could do this
console stuff still look like it's hard
to tell like literally the Microsoft
we're talking about right now between
now next year could change in an instant
mmm hold on brats thought I'd show rat
with a $10 suit a game pass is the entry
into becoming the Netflix of gaming I
ain't mad at Microsoft when they attend
Oh laughs you and soda so he kicks your
teeth in it's time to try something oh
so this side this is the fetus added to
practice what we say that's what we
doing look bad all that dough is like I
said to my point you know I feel
fulfilled in a sense that he's got a
tough he's got a tough sell because he's
got a piece of the haul most companies
would have sold the brand that happened
in 2013 it's a miracle Xbox is even
around because that that wasn't just a
small hit to the company that that was
like fallout 76 hit to Bethesda
Louisville why it was big they are
trying to rebound from one of the worst
starts to a generation I think it might
be the worst it might be I mean social
media day they got destroyed the
messaging was bad you know here's how
you trade use games you know we all know
it was a disaster so them getting off to
a good start is key but ignore and also
it seems like the strategy has changed
it seems like the game passing services
again based on what we have been hearing
Frank is the pitch to Sasha to say look
this is how much revenue this is what we
can do this is we are beneficial we are
profitable and it has shown short-term
to be working we are seeing developers
you know we'll have devs on soon or more
on Alpi that are saying like yo game
pass is a huge success that what's that
game anchorman descenders the sales
quadrupled just because it was in game
pass and it was that friend the question
becomes with gamers and I challenge to
chat if Microsoft is successful doing
this right but it means at the expense
of you know holding on to the exclusive
man to does that affect you with the
Xbox brand that's the internal question
I think as a
a more people after you see what's
important to them because if it is then
you may say hey I don't need Xbox right
I can go to PlayStation I'm gonna switch
I can go all these other places I can
get my get them their games I don't need
them all to any man's point like he said
when it's girl like yo this is great
value and I can stream I can do this I
can do all these things and I can have a
box if I want so it is interesting man
but um yeah she's no League I'm sorry
brother yes it is profitable that we've
got MPD stats map coach could tell I'll
bring him back on the show on we've had
developers countless developers saying
as far as Xbox game because again
short-term that it is extremely
profitable for them so that is factor
but anyway that's all I got so have you
got anything else on this or anything
else for you nah man it is really real
quick like he said I don't really care I
don't care where the games are right
honestly like I love having a console
and I love the fact they put you know
time and effort into making powerful
console I love that um at the end of the
day though if that's the industry is
moving someplace else I'm good as long
as the games come um but I do think you
know for the people to care about that
stuff right and I don't agree with that
point of view but if you care about it
and you hear the sort of stuff with them
leaving the door open I can see how you
could be bothered by that chat is all
fossil chats on fire you get obsessed
all go down okay so we have filly Eagle
with the $10 super jet thank you brother
or Bing search Brandi then search how
branding works if you're mad at
Microsoft publishing their branded work
so long it is a lot of stuff coming
through ecology another place that's a
you problem educator branding is their
goal which is true and they've made it
clear it made it clear it's just it's
funny when they do say maybe maybe not
who knows you know we've always out on
them for not being clear about stuff
alright so fixed I doubt now also the
daily gaming with the $2 of a chat game
your parents equals more Xbox platform
exclusives to sell it true throw the
additional revenue coming in from game
past obviously it gives them more
leverage to put more money into more
studios making more games so our games
is always a plus rag you matter that
ever so Dow
rap with the turnout superjet all jokes
aside Xbox can deliver first party
triple a bangers outside of halo and
have those games on gay past they could
have a leg up on Sony next-gen that's
gonna be the key man that's gonna be the
key to it it comes down to quality
ending games cuz you can have this great
stuff but if they're not great games
right it's like I said defeat the firm
like an attic in five years you know
well we could be talking about you know
Microsoft set themselves up like but in
five years we cannot be talking about
Xbox at all they just depends like you
know that they bought companies that you
know you don't really know what's gonna
happen like compulsion I would put them
on try to have like a kind of a Bioshock
filling going on game going on but we
don't know what they can do because at
the end of the day when they bought them
there was an inch of is your studio and
you can't really take those games and if
you have those kind of games going into
this gen with Microsoft backing them
then you could say something but right
now you can't take their past games and
act like that's what they could be
making for Microsoft because that is not
the case some of the studios that they
bought was on was on a crowdfunding so
outside of halo like the counters attics
point there is that they specifically
said like we're not trying to change
these Studios right well it's not to put
it out try I wasn't saying that I was
saying that what regardless if these
Studios wanted to do these things and
they did these games funding and stuff
was definitely gonna be an issue you
always like you can have the best talent
in the world they're like okay that
sounds cool right but what can we
realistically do with the bank account
well yeah and it gives them a dick
you're on it because that gives them
that that financial stability and gives
them creative control you know I'm
saying
one horse outside Ashley Lucas come
casted abilities show us some love of
our Lord must respect JD game again find
out a super chat Microsoft is doing the
rope-a-dope and we'll come out swinging
no it would be nobody boss no con you
gotta have to say Roper don't forget
like as I'm doing the rope-a-dope it
will continue to come out swinging
next-gen it will be a no-holds-barred
triple-a game past live explosion of
great gaming coming as Sony Oh get
addict oh we got the ground again we got
father's better get that way attic okay
so we got the Fargo super chat from the
ground gamer microsoft couldn't complete
this gen the traditional way so they
took another route to try and make the
most profit as possible its business so
they had to make moves you know what the
grounded gamer you're onto something
[ __ ] yourself brother you baby always up
but I mean listen if if it means this
hard look I gave you you know what you
you do something and have to change one
times you gotta you gotta be John Jones
and you know get get all kinds of stuff
I love it you know to see to start at
next generation to see how if this
strategy does pay off if you know who
knows we don't know right we don't know
we could just talk about what we see now
and what it seems appears to be but the
mindset is there more for way there's
gonna be interested to see if this
approach does pay off and if they're
competitive and in its crazy bastard a
lot a lot of these people lately so
developer wise is like yeah a lot of
them were crowd fun guys but you know
what mate maybe that's what needs to
happen
maybe these crowdfunding guys or maybe a
little battered and broken who you don't
know what to do anymore they maybe they
need to be adopted otherwise you know
maybe be charging their own Kickstarter
supporters for the game you already gone
did I place we act with you and I gave
that game like a six out of ten but you
know the world itself
is fantastically bill I really like the
story they tried to say but you know at
the end of the day it was it was
crowdfunded so yeah I mean you know if
maybe if Microsoft was back in that game
and and we happy fuse the first game
they made we could have a completely
different product but we would never
know something like that so that made
big money dejenne all I'm gonna say is
that again two addicts make it a good
point in a sense that a lot of these
studios acquired
there's something to be said about
having financial stability if something
is said to be having being able to take
chances with stuff that you wanted to do
that you might not have had that
security what Microsoft behind you
we're seeing with bleeding edge with
ninja to be able to do us another
project things like that all we hope is
these gains of quality and then they
come out any successful on the planet
and at the end of the day it's not like
they took the studio as is they updated
a lot of stuff they brought new they
brought an era communication with each
other which is a first which is what
Sony does which is what I like it
sometimes you know we could have a case
of death stranding happening where
there's no one over there to question
coach emic achievement that don't make
sense but you know maybe that's gonna
happen in these studios as they hired
new people you know what something says
something you know that makes no sense
you know what you're right Kojima don't
got that I think a Jeeva has some cachet
know even if he was I will see wait wait
that's what I got man last time is this
be me and salt will flock to it cuz the
king is not here who was with us shout
to senado and shout out to hi who was at
play oh one last super chat JD game on
fire right look harder you know go and
maudette to JD I'm pissed a Twitter just
talking about Shenmue 3 if that game
wasn't crowdfunding maybe the characters
would have some off a shoe oh don't
start Jay I was gonna module
oh he encouraged it anchorman slander
what you've been slamming it anyway this
would be for me in a sub because the
kings that hail forced a shot to hide
shots now though all those it came
through play NYC saw we came through the
lords were there last week no Widow
gaming convention had a lot of things on
display just real quick some personal
highlights just how you feel you know
about the convention in New York gaming
in general I just like the fact that you
know after about an hour - it got full
it's not a big convention space but it
shows that people like are really
interested in in a East Coast developers
and and finding a place for his Coast
developers to congregate on the East
Coast I'm interested in growing that and
specifically for play crafting the you
know the ones that put on play NYC it's
a lot more than just uh just a
convention right play crafting is kind
of it like an entire network of game
designers and creators coming together
sort of support each other to sort of uh
educate themselves on on game on
development techniques in addition to
like being really nurturing of new
people trying to come into the industry
and how to do that so it's beyond just
the convention is it's a big community
trying trying to grow a big community on
the East Coast so I thought it was great
a lot of those titles that we saw I
really loved that specifically
interested in fiction spear that was
shoes there was fire yeah beautifully
side-scrolling action game and I mean
the combat in the game it's just it
looks like a beautiful like you know
SNES inside calling game um kung fu
kickball shout out to Joan fun well food
well food games and Jonah aka willful
games of course game a game about choice
Wow thank you brother with the $20 suit
which I think but I enjoy playing games
I don't care if they're exclusive or not
I just want great games for all
forms great show as always panel thank
you brother drinking the lot man
spreading spreading the word man I
appreciate you brother thank you
sure oh yeah so um the app obviously the
interview with the CEO damn butch Co
he's been you know the fact that he's
been with us from the very beginning and
every single year he's trying to grow it
into something bigger I think it's
amazing and I think you know everybody
who's on the East Coast whether it be
youtubers were it could be people in the
development community need to start
supporting this event and make it grow
cuz it's on us um really I want to jump
in on that point too so first of all
shout out to Nevada a salir in the chat
right now because he always supports us
but I see him when we put those those
videos even if it's the most obscure
game he would give his commentaries and
look to you on that but yeah I mean
solve you want man because um first of
all ooh the Lord damn butch cold man I
just pioneer in this vision for New York
you know what I'm saying is it's just
it's tremendous man and please y'all if
you haven't seen it the articles up on
logic gaming dotnet the interview that
we hit we had with Dan okay it was
tremendous time the CEO of it was just
amazing hold on did dizzy sled you know
like what I say New York is the Beca
again he is in Texas I will give him
that they have like two events there
quakecon and tax I'll respect that but
we come in we come and I you Texas boy
get out of control it was tremendous so
please you're like I said support these
developers support these it's like to me
know that what's awful is like seeing
homegrown talent like it feels like
wheezing a babies or triple a little
shove it up you know and just to see
like I said shout the fiction's fish out
of various verses the first fantasy PvP
game you know no course not the voice
I'm decoy swims deep voice and he's out
here Wow mine is dome absolutely
twin-stick shooter
the game is self-published it's gonna be
our own multi-platforms you know I'm
saying Xbox Playstation switch to it's a
ton of fun
tremendous more again please check out
we got a lot
content up for playing watch it big
shout out to the back Scratchy
oh that we shot shout the king for doing
you dirty I got a cookie baked did you
dirty says cuz he had you with that back
scratcher yeah you gotta pay this sound
like I don't care that footage he took I
almost peed myself he's a fool
yo but yo it was just good to see New
York gaming alive and well and you know
they're slowly gonna come away Texas yet
so I see you fast back I see you dizzy
we know what it is but New York is
coming
careful we are gonna come up you know
Sam but it was good to see but uh that's
no fall they order I don't want to see
that mess again
I was just waiting on art cuz you know
they scroll through different bags right
so I was just waiting for the fat dude
with the hairy back Oh have your friend
catch his back and put the bad big day
was no sleep on your Jersey was in the
building was in the building state New
York Georgia Connecticut Boston they all
was there wrapping map telling you but
your scrout yo phone's going he said
solve like happy to dispatch new il
people let's get out of here man oh all
right so up this week when you hear of
studio leads I love this one
or prominent developer departures prior
to the launch of a title how concerned
are you about the quality of the title
moving forward a very concerned based on
the level of the departure be minimal
concern devs leave jobs every day B or C
I don't care unless it's my favorite
game
that is the question those are the
choices please Rock the aisle people
when he goes up on Twitter tomorrow lord
anchorman in the building just like old
times hole holes it is bad jumping out
of retirement
oh the cake board hold us down baby kick
that way can a 5 people find you what do
you have going on sir
you guys can find me on anchorman b2 on
PlayStation Xbox which YouTube whatever
you guys see that we're starting a
multi-part show next month I'm actually
going I'm actually working on the new
layout because we are moving to discord
for the show we're gonna be doing that
but we're still on YouTube recently put
it up on there but I just add we're
moving to different formats inside
Google Hangouts is going extinct later
this year so vintage anchor fraud a leg
which comics for you that was a stay
with I was gonna show you know I'm like
a like old Captain America now you moved
on from that always welcome in the realm
answered the call for us my gaming
brother good to see you brother always
always a pleasure of course we got Lord
addict about to get out of here real
quick hold it down get in the table
height getting the panel hyping Kings
absence wicked if I'm people find what
you got on going on Lord of reviews it
definitely catch my man forgot what the
name of that game was yeah and such is
like I see I have that review could
check the written form in case you yeah
you keep Lords of gaming but you can
definitely catch it over there in case
you're one of those only read weirdos
but you know definitely go there yeah I
want to thank you know every one of the
super chats you know
definitely really appreciate that you
guys get with some mad love this this
week you know you know those goat or
stuff like eat three trips you know you
guys are the reason we're able to go to
those and I definitely appreciate that
absolutely I mean you couldn't set it
much better I mean again I mean thanks
to you guys you know saying super Chad
to support and dative is so petty right
I can't but uh thanks to support like
you guys really help us get out to these
shows it really means a ton especially
the articles in between that all that
stuff helps us man
Big Time Lord sovereign fighting the
good air you guys the astronaut Twitter
Lord saw by Opie and be accelerant on
PSN Xbox Live yeah now that I'm done
with blood stain I think maybe maybe
I'll go back to uh the Youngblood but I
wasn't you know I wasn't too impressed
with Youngblood but uh excited man next
couple of weeks are gonna be crazy like
and the August into September man we got
a control coming up yeah astral chain we
got Blair which got man of May dawn and
that's just a blur which is already
coming out and then you know man of
Madonna and that's just like August and
then we go right into gears in September
funny stuff coming out of worlds so it
has begun
salute to so that all don't know [ __ ]
salute to getting Ronnie game thank you
so much brother
we got two giveaways y'all just before
we go to giveaways I said we got gears
five yeah come with your copy before
release and of course Borderlands three
man please please check that out it is
going to be sweet is it is it an actual
copy of the game or is it gonna be like
oh here's the game pass please again
support that we got that going on trying
to give back to the community again and
again support my brother King he was not
feeling well he's got ko
what's up earlier this week of fantastic
fantastic ghostrider
up right now on lords a game without net
please check out Johnny Blaze and all
its glory and of course please show
mommy I know you guys not everybody like
destiny but please show my boy a bonta's
and myself love the last word part at
last word part we got a Twitter account
up we got audio up put it in the chat
yeah we just had on what you called Paul
Tassie on from Forbes it was absolutely
tremendous man oh man you got to go
check that I better give you guys this
information in a second because the last
word pod is moving out here in these
streets and you got a support and even
if you don't like destiny you got
support so that's when we got there um
anything else going on in the future do
you talk about we not gonna talk about
this yet
so we just put this into chat real quick
already did okay thank you brother yeah
even if just go in there hear the like
man get like button hit the chat I put
the Twitter Cup please if you guys
follow our little podcast follow at last
word pod please file that we need to
follow us up get to get the word out
there if you like Lou the shooters were
talking we don't have some more bigger
guest it's gonna be lit man but that's
all I got everybody's got to go if
anybody's got anything else is the
Lord's good if not everybody enjoy your
Sunday we are out peace